. Also, you can join the discussion with 26000
other viewers and listeners. Imagine that
on our sub. Read it at David Pakman dot com
slash redit. That's all. Read it. This morning
I spotted an interesting post asking on the sub
Reddit whether Rudy Giuliani could be disbarred
for these sham voter frauds hearings, that voter
fraud hearings that he is doing, setting up a
parallel legal system. You know, there's actually
a very interesting double edged sword here.
On the one hand, Rudy Giuliani's presence at these
hearings making bogus claims of voter fraud with
ridiculous affidavits and completely deranged
witnesses, some of whom I'll play video of
momentarily. On the one hand, his behavior is
completely unbecoming of an agent of the court. At
the same time, they're not really legally relevant
hearings in any way. And what I mean by that is
they are sometimes held in hotel rooms. Nobody
is under oath and they are meaningless from
a legal perspective. So the double edged
sword is if these were legal proceedings,
then what Rudy is doing would absolutely, in my
view, suggest that maybe this guy should not be an
officer of the court. At the same time, these are
sham proceedings. So therefore, they don't even
really count as not really they do not count as
legal proceedings. They are not legal proceedings,
which makes it a very bizarre situation.
And I don't expect there will be any
bar repercussions for Rudy Giuliani whatsoever.
Another post from the sub Reddit asking about
the upcoming elections, saying there will
be more complete Trumpy and candidates
and even more Akua believers elected at
lower levels in swing state legislatures
in twenty twenty two and twenty twenty four.
I actually don't know that the ship has sailed
on that. I don't know that the ink is dry,
so to speak, on whether we will see bonkers,
Trumpy and Kuhnen candidates in 22 and 24. I
think it will depend on whether Donald Trump
remains a visible element during the next couple
of years or whether he disappears. If Donald Trump
I mean, listen, he's doing a rally on
Saturday for the Georgia Senate races.
But if Donald Trump disappears to just play golf
for the next few years, I actually think that the
the appetite and enthusiasm behind these Trump
and Kuhnen candidates will completely deflate.
On the other hand, if Donald Trump, as some have
suggested, goes directly into his 2024 24 campaign
after Joe Biden is inaugurated, I do think that
there is a strong likelihood that we will see
Kuhnen and Trumpy and candidates in the
midterms and maybe even into into 2024.
We will follow it. And I encourage you to join
the discussion at David Pakman Dotcom. Read it.